.Attention à la fin de la vidéo. J'ai une annonce à vous faire, pour vous offrir quelques cadeaux, donc regardez là.
Salut, pour ce lundi de vlog je vais vous emmener avec moi en Suisse
là je pars dans quelques minutes
au Lido Comédie Club pour la dernière du Lido Comédie & Club de Lausanne
La valise est prête
Il y a ce soir une programmation de ouf pour la fermeture de ce lieu. C'est une triste fermeture.
Et ce lieu culturel va disparaître du coup tous les artistes qui sont passés là bas ces dernières années
se retrouvent là bas pour faire un gros plateau de fête, un gros plateau de dernière.
Et évidemment je vous emmène avec moi
C'est bon je viens d'arriver à Lausanne, on a eu un retard de ouf. Plus de 2 heures de retard dans le train
Le public rentre dans la salle dans... ou il y a, plutot,  10 minutes
Donc je suis très très en retard.
Là j'ai tout mis en vrac ce qui veut dire que je vais grave le regretter ce soir car on va rentrer très tard, je prends le train très tôt demain
et il faudra tout ranger... en fait
- Après y'a Fromage, Jambon/Fromage
C'est une grosse organisation
si vous voulez boire des verres pendant le spectacle
enfin pendant tout le temps
Vous me demandez à moi
F: Ça c'est le régisseur
Seb: Hello
F: Qui ressemble grave à Seb Mellia
S: Ecoutez...
F: C'est ouf
S: ... au vue de ma carrière
j'ai fait un choix assez judicieux
F: *rire*
S: Je me suis orienté vers la régie
et les pizzas
En fait je me bats mais c'est... c'est la même
F: *rire* C'est ça, en fait, j'ai l'impression que tu revis toujours le même moment
S: C'est la même partout
F: La Pizza sans fin
S: On est sur une grande tristesse au niveau de la répartition du poulet
F: Elle fait tellement mal au cœur Christelle Berrou
C: Non mais c'est parce que j'ai demandé un pizza végétalienne
et en fait ils m'ont mis juste des tomates et de la salade alors qu'en fait ils auraient pu mettre pleins de trucs: Des champignons, des aubergines...
C'est un peu comme ci j''étais punie
F: C'est ça
C: Je suis punie j'ai pas fait assez de blagues
F: Dans ton grand siège, où tu as l'air toute petite dedans
C: Je suis pas assez drôle alors du coup j'ai rien à manger
- Bonjour Eux
C'est qui "Eux"?
F: YouTube
- Tu connais c'est qui "Eux"
- Eux
F: Tu peux dire "Bonjour YouTube"
- Bonjour YouTube
C'est bon la pizza
- A remettre ça sur pied et tu espères devenir célèbre en mettant des trucs, des conneries comme ça
F: En mettant toi surtout en mettant toi
- Bravo. Ouaiiis
C: Ben oui j'ai taché ma robe, ça va mais...
F: Ça c'est tout l'intérêt de mettre une robe très fleurie
C: Ben oui parce que croire que... limite je peux mettre un bout de salade
F: Mais bien sûr ça se marrie extrêmement bien
C: Regarde ben oui
Merci je savais pas que tu étais styliste en plus d'être mentaliste
*Applaudissement de la salle*
F: Quand tout le monde est debout dans la salle ça veut dire qu'il y a trop de monde et qu'il y a pas assez de chaises.
- Avec un artiste qui nous viens de France
et qui est mentaliste
C'est Fabien Olicard. Merci de faire du bruit pour lui
*Applaudissement du public en folie.*
F: Bonsoir, Bonsoir, comme tout le monde ce soir je suis ravi d'être là même si c'est pas pour une bonne nouvelle par contre c'est une bonne nouvelle d'être avec vous
Thomas vous l'a dit je m'appelle Fabien et je suis mentaliste, donc ce soir je vais vous mentaliser
*cri du public*
F: Monsieur quel est votre prénom?
- Gabriel
F: Gabriel... exactement
*rires du public*
Il y a quelques années quand je disais que j'étais mentaliste personne ne savait ce que c'était
et maintenant qu'il y a eu la série The Mentalist
personne ne sait ce que c'est, ça n'a rien changé
*rires*
Le mentalisme c'est 2 choses: C'est la manière d'influencer vos choix et de savoir ce que vous pensez
Par exemple mademoiselle
c'est très flatteur ce que tu penses
*rires du public*
Je la regarde elle se dit mon pauvre garçon pas du tout
*rires*
Est ce un article un mot court quelques choses comme ça?
- ??
*rires du public*
F: Elle avait pas révisé
F: un article comme le, la, les, un, des
- Non
F: C'est un vrai mot
D'accord
Je pense que c'est ça. Est ce que tu peux le dire à quel mot tu pensais s'il te plait ?
- Au ski
F: Au Ski... au ski OUI
*applaudissement du public*
F: Alors tu vas imaginer ta mère devant toi
je vais te donner pleins de détails sur elle
et au fur et à mesure tu me diras si j'ai bon ou pas
F: Alors avant de le révéler, j'aimerai que tu nous l'as présente. Comment s'appelle ta maman stp Marianne?
- Françoise
F: Françoise. FRANÇOISE
*Applaudissement du public*
F: Un tonnerre d'applaudissement pour Marianne
*Applaudissement*
F: Merci beaucoup. C'était un plaisir de vous mentaliser
- Merci à Fabien Olicard
- Kyan, Fabien Olicard
Venez tous
[Présentation de tous les artistes]
Christine Berrou, Navo, Yacine Belhousse, Blaise Bersinger, Carlos Henriquez
François Martinez, Seb Melia,
Charles Nouveau,  Alex Kominek
Yoann Provenzano, Arek Gurunian
Carlos Henriquez, Christophe Bugnon, Edem Labah, Frederic Gerard, Jacques Bonvin, Jessie Kobel, Jonas Schneiter, Kaya Güner, Malvin & Renaud, Marina Rollman, Nadim, Nathalie Devantay, Nathanael Rochat, Pascal Vincent, Sandrine Viglino, Tamara Cesar, Thomas Wiesel, Vincent Kohler et la Comédie Musicale Improvisée.
- Merci à vous tous. C'est grâce à vous que l'on vit quoi.
Mille Merci
J'espère que ce petit vlog que la Suisse vous a plu
On a pas pu avoir beaucoup d'images. C'était compliqué. On était 30 artistes
Juste après la outro, je vous fais l'annonce que les choses que je voulais vous offrir
Et si ce vlog vous a plu, n'hésitez pas à me le faire savoir en me laissant par exemple, peut être, un petit
Pouce en l'air
N'oubliez pas également de vous abonner avant de partir puisque le MentalVlog c'est une vidéo par jour pendant un an
depuis ce 1er janvier jusqu'au 31 décembre.
Donc rendez vous demain à 17h
Ciao !
Si vous me suivez sur les réseaux sociaux, sur Snap, Instagram, Facebook ou Twitter
Vous avez vu il y a quelques jours le site du Goëland.fr m'a envoyé quelques nouveaux tee-shirts pour les vidéos.
Et ça, c'est plutôt sympa de leur part, c'est parce qu'ils ont vu que je portais leurs tee-shirts dans les vidéos
Et avec les tee-shirts ils m'ont envoyé pleins d'autocollants
Genre ça
ça
ou encore ça
alors j'en ai gardé un de chaque exemplaire pour moi. Et je me suis dis simplement vous offrir les autres
donc je fais un concours simple
Vous m'envoyez un mail à l'adresse qui va s'afficher ici et que je vous mets dans le descriptif
C'est une adresse mail que pour le concours donc m'écrivez pas pour autre chose dessus
Vous m'envoyez donc un mail à cette adresse avec votre nom, votre prénom, votre adresse, et votre age.
Et en fin de semaine grâce à un des sites que vous m'avez conseillé, je ferai un tirage au sort
de  5 personnes à qui j'enverrai 3 autocollants et également le jeu que j'offre dans mon spectacle
qui est un jeu qui permet de mentaliser les gens 3 fois
Voilà, j'espère que ça vous fera plaisir, parce que moi ça me fait plaisir de vous offrir ça.
A bientôt. Ciao !